around the world more people are
suffering hardship
than ever before every year it seems
when the un announces the money it needs
to deal with humanitarian emergencies
across the globe
the figures get bigger and bigger the un
estimates that because of covid19 235
million people
will need humanitarian assistance an
increase of 40
over the figure last year it's appealing
for 35 billion dollars to meet the need
as the darkest and bleakest i ever seen
in more than 35 years of doing this kind
of work
and what's happened is we've had the
accumulation over many years of
conflict problems and climate change
problems and now
on top of that we've got the if you like
the triple whammy of covet
because of coverage we've got a 40
increase the biggest increase we've ever
had in the number of people
who might not survive next year without
help and assistance to 235 million
people
yemen is still the worst humanitarian
emergency
in the world the un has identified 56
countries
that most need assistance what's
worrying them is that many of those
have a deteriorating situation and there
are new places being added to the list
this year ethiopia
nagorno-karabakh and mozambique james
bay's
al jazeera of the united nations